>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Harriett Green: And I'm
really excited to join this day
of invigorating discussions about
our Digital Collections as Data.
And I'll be speaking,
as Kate indicated,
about the new initiative we've
launched to train librarians
in methods for digital research.
So, I'll first give -- briefly
give context around the issues
that motivated our projects
and some of the landscape,
and then talk about
our project itself.
So, as we've seen and heard
from presenters earlier today,
accessible digitized content
and data is increasing rapidly,
and the roles of libraries
are changing accordingly
as more researchers and
teachers integrate data
into their work and scholarship.
As the Association for Research
Libraries Strategic Thinking
and Design Initiative
report, declares in its vision
of the future, "In 2033, the
research library will have shifted
from its role as a knowledge service
provider within the university,
to become a collaborative
partner within a rich
and diverse learning
and research ecosystem."
End quote.
This future declaration
frames how librarians are
and will encounter new needs
and types of research queries
that challenge our
skill sets, knowledge,
and scope of library services.
And it's been made evident
today, the deluge is eminent
for the humanities and social
sciences, as much as the sciences.
So, in light of all this data
that we have in the humanities
and social sciences, how
can libraries prepare
for [inaudible] supporting,
emergent data-driven research?
So, I won't repeat the points made
by previous presenters about data,
but I wanted to highlight
this characterization of data
from the Our Cultural
Commonwealth report,
published about ten years
ago from the American Council
of Learned Societies,
because it's in the context
of building cyberinfrastructure for
the humanities and social sciences.
And it defines concisely but
thoroughly the richly diverse types
of data that research needs,
and the report goes on to say
that cyberinfrastructure
isn't just the hardware
and the software, but
it's the people.
And to quote, "A cyberinfrastructure
for humanities
and social sciences must encourage
interactions between the expert
and the amateur, the creative
artist and the scholar,
the teacher and the student.
It's not just the collection
of data, digital
or otherwise, that matters.
At least as important as the
activity that goes around it,
contributes to it, and
eventually integrates with it."
End quote.
So, of equal importance to the
data, is the researcher, teacher,
and librarian/research
expert who explore,
expand, and curate the data.
That's where [inaudible] and what
libraries are and should be doing
to engage in digital scholarship.
So, there've been a number
of studies in recent years
that have looked at how libraries
are accommodating their spaces,
services, and personnel, to serve
in digital scholarship needs.
And among others, the newly released
ARL SPEC Kit 350 by Rick Mulligan
on digital scholarship
centers and libraries,
found that support
is relatively new,
so that of the responding libraries,
67% of the digital scholarship
library personnel had joined
within the last five years,
and 75% have been doing this digital
scholarship work only for less
than 5 years, and digital
scholarship support is frequently
distributed across the libraries,
for the librarians and archivists
to professional support
staff, and student assistance.
Support for digital scholarship
in libraries is growing
rapidly, but is still nascent.
And then on the individual level,
other studies have examined what
librarians are doing digital
scholarship now and what is needed.
So, there've been two recent
volumes from ACRL and Purdue,
that present a variety of use cases
of digital humanities
programs and projects.
And groups such as ACRL's
Digital Humanities Interest Group,
and the new library special
interest group, and the Association
for Digital Humanities
Organizations,
are spaces where library
and communities involved
in DH, are growing.
And then several libraries have
also begun to launch programs
to train their librarians in
digital scholarship skills,
such as University of Maryland's
DH Incubator which Trevor will talk
about in a few minutes, the Columbia
Library's Developing Librarian,
and Harvard Library Lab among
many other -- several others.
But despite these initial advances,
there's a still a ways to go.
And how can we empower all
academic librarians to engage
with digital scholarship
and new forms of research?
So, this is where our
project intends to step in.
We've proposed a project
to the Institute of Museum
and Library Services
which they kindly funded,
that's called "Digging
Deeper, Reaching Further,
Libraries Empowering Users
to Mine Hathi Trust
Digital Library Resources."
So, for the next few minutes, I'll
talk about how our project seeks
to build librarians'
capacities and skills
in digital scholarship methods,
specifically by connecting
librarians to collections,
digital collections,
via skill-building
and research methods
for tech mining.
So, to first talk about
our motivations
and philosophies for the project.
To set the context,
our work is based
in the Hathi Trust Research
Center which is the research arm
of the Hathi Trust Digital Library.
Many of you may be familiar with
the Hathi Trust Digital Library,
as a digital library of over
14 million digitized texts
and materials, over 5
billion pages at last count.
In the Hathi Trust Ecosystem,
the digital library collects digital
content, provides public access,
and preserves the digital content,
while at the research center,
we enable researchers to gather
content from the digital library
into curated datasets, or what we
call work sets, and then analyze
and produce new scholarly findings.
The Hathi Trust Research Center
is jointly led by the University
of Illinois, Urbana-Champaign, and
Indiana University Bloomington,
and we collaborate on
research development
of HTRC services and
researcher support.
And we most prominently facilitate
researcher access to textural data,
so at the moment, you can obtain
access to the public domain corpus
as full text and then other
more granular formats,
but our ultimate goal is to provide
access to both out of copyright
and in copyright text, via tools
that facilitate non-consumptive
research.
My HTRC colleagues are working on
these new developments very soon,
and that's a -- more details can
be found on our website for that.
But as we develop tools and
research resources in the HTRC,
we increasingly realize that in
order to develop effective services
for users, we need to know
how to go about their work,
and learn firsthand from them,
what they need to do or --
and/or support large scale
text analysis research.
So, in the last year, we conducted a
user assessment study for the HTRC,
consisting of about 15 to
16 interviews thus far,
with scholars from a
variety of disciplines,
technologists and librarians.
The HTRC team members, Alex
Kinnaman, Eleanor Dickson,
and Peter Organisciak,
did some initial analysis
of the interview data
that we've coded,
to develop preliminary
user personas.
The digital project
librarian, the faculty member,
and the graduate student.
And so, we're finalizing
our analysis,
and these personas are not concrete
by any means, but they begin
to characterize the different levels
of users that engage with our data.
You have the faculty team member,
researcher with advanced
tools or advanced needs.
The newer graduate student
researcher who's still exploring
methods and tools.
And then there is the
research support personnel,
characterized here as the
digital project librarian.
And this user persona of the
digital project librarian,
particularly caught our
eye and affirmed something
that we'd been considering.
As we seek to engage researchers
and using the collections
of the Hathi Trust Digital
Library, in their scholarship,
we realized that librarians
are a critical linchpin
in connecting researchers to the
data and tools, as they strive
to provide access to data and
match tools to the researchers.
Well, and there's the circle.
And so, in 2015, we were awarded a
three-year Laura Bush 21st Century
Librarian Program Grant
from the Institute
of Museum Library Services,
to develop a digital
scholarship training program
from academic librarians,
as titled there.
And I want to highlight the
word "empowerment" in our title
because empowerment
is key to our program.
We seek to teach librarians
about the fundamental approaches
to text mining, how to
work with textual data,
and then as I'll explain in a
minute, enable them to teach others.
And then given that the HTRC
is the anchor for our training
and the textual data
is core to the HTRC,
the focus of curriculum
is on text mining.
But our goals are preparing
librarians in ways and able them
to support digital
scholarship more broadly.
So, here are our formal
goals, as listed up here.
Arming librarians with new
content for instructional services
that address the curricular
and research needs of students
and faculty pursuing digital
scholarship, empower librarians
to become active research
partners on digital projects
at their institutions, and
provide foundational knowledge
to transform academic library
[inaudible] commons and DH centers
into more data intensive,
collaborative learning spaces,
through the use of this curriculum
and the knowledge that enables them
to participate in scholarly
dialogues.
So, our project team is listed here.
It's led by me, and then the co-PIs
include my Illinois colleagues Beth
Namachchivaya and Steven Downie, and
we have four partner institutions
who span different sizes and types
of higher education institutions.
So, in the end, at University
Bloomington, which again,
is our HCRC partner as well and
is led by co-PI, Angela Courtney.
Lafayette College, a
liberal arts college,
Dean Neil McElroy and
Terese Heidenwolf.
Northwestern University
with co-PI, Geoff Morse.
And University of North
Carolina, Chapel Hill,
Stewart Varner was our original
co-PI, but with his departure
to Penn, Amanda Henley
is now joining our team.
So, the project began
in October 2015, again,
and we spent the last year
developing the curriculum but ceased
to train librarians and [inaudible]
professionals in approaches
and tools frequently used
in text mining research.
And this year, we're now
launching pilot workshops,
at all five partner
institutions, this fall and spring,
to test drive the curriculum.
So, to talk about the
curriculum in a bit of detail,
the anchor of the curriculum is
the tools and services in the HTRC.
So, we teach them to work
with the HRTC portal,
which enables researchers to again,
build datasets of text, work sets,
from the public domain corpus, and
the Hathi Trust Digital Library,
and then they can run a selection
of data mining algorithms
that are preinstalled with the
portal, of course with the caveats
that were mentioned earlier today.
And then also, we are teaching
them how to extract other ways
of getting Hathi Trust data
through things such as the API
and what we call "extracted
features."
But we also realize that librarians
operate in many different contexts
and field a wide range of
research questions, so,
our focus to really teach about
the fundamentals about text mining,
and perhaps what we might
call "data science skills."
We introduce participants to the
command line, how to harvest data
through web-scraping, how
to clean tabular data,
and how to run basic Python
scripts for data manipulation
and basic types of text
analysis such as word frequency.
Our curriculum is targeted
at beginners mostly,
and the platforms we use in
teaching, such as PythonAnywhere,
are -- end up making these skills
and activities as widely accessible
as possible, in various
teaching environments.
And so, we ultimately aim to build
foundational skills in text mining
in librarians, through a
train the trainer approach.
After the attendees participate in
our workshops, we hope to put them
on the road to developing
these foundational skills,
and they also will be given a full
suite of instructional resources
and tools at their disposal
to then teach the workshops
at their own institutions.
So, next year, after
we do the pilots
and refine the curriculum
a bit more,
we'll conduct a nationwide
road show workshops
that will train LIS
professionals at major conferences
and in key geographic areas
around the United States,
and teaching both the HTRC
rules and the principles
of large scale text mining.
After the workshops conclude,
we will refine our materials,
one last time, and
then release a tool kit
that will contain a finalized
package of the curriculum materials,
tutorials, and other resources that
all librarians can take and use,
and it'll be hosted on our
open institutional repository.
And another outcome we hope to
build is a network community
of librarians, who want to
continue these conversations
and share their experiences as
they begin to teach text mining
and digital scholarship
at their own institutions.
And also, throughout the project,
we'll be conducting a research study
that assesses the process
of curriculum development
for digital scholarship methods
and also examine strategies
for LIS professional development.
In this way, we hope to
build a community practice
around a curriculum as the trainers
become -- trainees become trainers.
So, our project I believe will
be a significant step forward
in addressing the questions
of how do we build skills
in digital humanities
and digital scholarship,
and for data driven
research in our libraries.
And I propose that there
are a couple particular,
larger issues that we should
consider and begin to think --
rethink about librarianship as
we increase our interactions
with digital scholarship work.
So, first as been made clear
by previous presenters today,
we need to re-conceptualize our work
and collection curation
and engagement.
So, [inaudible] our librarians
are collection managers,
but most of us touch and interact
with collections, and various ways
for reference to cataloging,
to information architecture
and interface design.
And with the rapid rise in digital
collections and our own holding
as well as throughout
the scholarly landscape,
from the vast digital
resources, such as the Hathi Trust
through to our small local digital
collections, librarians will have
to engage with collections as
digital curators become familiar
with data acquisition,
and think broader --
think about the broader multiplicity
of ways that users want to engage
with our collections in
digital and physical formats.
And another key area
and opportunity along
with this is how librarians
can engage in more points
in the research lifecycle.
So, scholars across the disciplines
are gathering varying amounts
of data, incorporating
data in different stages
of the research process, and are
looking to the library as a source
of research support beyond
just providing research
and reference guidance.
And this is reflected in the
changing nature of who we're hiring
in the library for areas such
as data curation, GIS analysis,
and data and scholarly publishing.
The 2011, Value of
Academic Libraries Report
from the Association of
College and Research Libraries,
notes that quote, "Research
collaborations between faculty
and librarians, continue
to benefit both partners.
Faculty benefit from library
resources and librarian expertise.
Librarians benefit
from the opportunity
to secure the library's future as
a significant partner in research
and scholarship," end quote.
The Value Report is only one of
a number of studies that suggest
that research partnerships
between researchers
and librarians is more
necessary than ever.
So, in conclusion,
I believe projects
such as ours will catalyze broader
thought processes on how to train
and prepare librarians
to meet the demands
of data driven research
and scholarship.
We might consider these questions.
What infrastructures do
libraries need to build or revise
for supporting digital scholarship?
How do we empower librarians
to build the skills needed
to respond to new research needs?
And how can librarians
share skills, materials,
and resources for supporting
digital scholarship?
So, as we think more about how
do we translate our collections
into usable and accessible
data, I believe that the skills
and research connections forged
by librarians with faculty
and researchers will be key
to advancing our success.
So, I want to thank again, the
IMLS for supporting our project,
as well as the Hathi
Trust Research Center,
and our partnering institutions,
image credits, and thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Trevor Munoz: Device switcheroo.
I have learned after a
long, painful experience,
that I can't type my password and
start talking at the same time.
So, my computer is very secure
but I definitely can't
multitask for that password.
So, I want to say that
I'm absolutely thrilled
to have been invited to speak today,
alongside so many folks
doing such amazing work.
I hope that there is not a level of
jaded cynicism at which you know,
getting to speak at the Library
of Congress is not really
all that, because it is.
And I'm particularly pleased to
be on this panel for two reasons.
One, because my co-panelists
are both people
from whom I have learned a lot
and whom I continue
to look to, to learn.
But also, because this topic
of developing communities
of practice is one that I have a
lot of complicated feelings about
and that I love to talk about.
So, am I'm going to try to do this
in the context of this initiative
that we're working on the at
the University of Maryland,
"Synergies Among Digital Humanities
and African American
History and Culture."
And in a couple minutes, we're
going to put that sort of front
and center, but I wanted
to just sort
of make one other personal note,
which is to say that I engage
with collections, you know,
sort of me personally,
I engage with collections
as data in a number of ways.
I occasionally write code to do some
analysis or satisfy a curiosity.
I have been guilty of committing
the occasional data visualization.
However, my main job is to work
with people who are doing things
with collections or want to
do things with collections,
and these are both analog
and digital collections.
Or maybe more precisely, my
job is to help bring together
and facilitate groups of humans
who are engaged with data.
And so, I want to talk about
the ways in which we're thinking
through some of the
issues that arise
in the context of this initiative.
So, "Synergies Among
Digital Humanities
and African American History
and Culture," is the formal name
of our project, but
it's far too long
to keep saying over and over again.
So, we also refer to it
as the AADHUM Initiative,
and that's what I'll
be doing henceforth.
You'll notice that English grammar
forces us to put those terms
in one order for euphony,
but it is important
that the African American part
comes first, AADHUM, ADDHUM.
So, this is our project hashtag,
where hopefully we will be able
to have further conversation
around this topic.
And I should also say that
what you're hearing today is
of course only one voice from
what is already a sort of large
and multifaceted initiative.
So, this is me.
That's my Twitter handle,
my contact information.
But of course, I'm also speaking
to you as a member of a community,
or really multiple
other communities.
The people who have been
working hard for two years
to make this initiative a reality at
Maryland, the team of people beyond
that who are now joining the project
and contributing their skills.
And yet, even though this
project is only really seven
or eight months old,
already the number of people,
the community of people
who are engaged
in this work, is quite large.
So, I can only speak to you know,
the limits of my personal experience
and my reflections on the work that
we are collectively doing together.
And I think it's important not to
forget that we are always enmeshed
in these larger communities.
And I'll come back to
that point in a second.
So, the website for today's event
explained in the kind of intro text,
that "The rise of accessible digital
collections," I'm quoting here,
"coupled with development of tools
for processing and analyzing data,
has enabled researchers
to create new models
of scholarship and inquiry."
I'm a humanist, so I
can't help sort of picking
at the terms of the debate.
And so, I think one way that we
can then understand communities
of practice, is as one model of
these new modes of scholarship
and inquiry, which is to
say, communities are part
of how accessible digital
collections may be coupled with
or may fail to be coupled with tools
for processing and analyzing data
to do work that matters
to other humans.
And so, my basic premise then is
that a world of collections as data,
depends upon the design and
nurturing of communities.
And the phrase, "communities
of practice," I think is an --
it's important to realize
that this is a subset, right?
The phrase "communities of
practice," is a term of art
and it comes from a
particular place.
To sketch this history, very briefly
and to do it absolutely no justice
at all, the original nexus for
the concept of "communities
of practice," is in
workplace anthropology
and it was chiefly focused on
understanding adult learning
and improving adult learning.
And it was further developed
to describe sort of ad hock
and improvised ways of sharing
knowledge within organizations,
within workplaces, to
quote, "Get the job done,"
when existing knowledge or
managerial direction falls short.
And of course, people who've engaged
with this idea have
also been interested
in how these practices create and
reshape the identities of workers,
and thus perhaps, unsurprisingly,
the concept of "communities
of practice" have been taken up
and discussed as a managerial tool,
especially for breaking
through institutional barriers
and promoting, quote, "innovation."
Andrew Cox has provided a very
useful overview of the seminal works
on community of practice in
a 2005 article in the Journal
of Information Science, for those
of you who are interested in more.
And the progression that he
traces is certainly toward a more
and more sort of organizational
studies, managerial approach,
to communities of practice.
And so, then what should we take
from the career of this term
of our communities of practice,
as a concept to take back with us
for our reflections on how we
think about collections as data.
Certainly, there is much to like.
Learning as an active,
social process,
not a mechanical transfer
of skills and knowledge.
The emphasis on improvising
new forms of work
when old ones no longer suit.
The seductive allure of breaking
through institutional barriers
and building a group identity
with other like-minded folks.
Certainly, I think the
energy around today's event,
is certainly an expression of
the hunger that we often feel
when we use a term like
"communities of practice," right?
We want to find others like us
who are doing things the
way that we're doing.
And that can be both beneficial
and I think it can also block us
from seeing other things.
So, what might the two easy
acceptance of communities
of practice as our vehicle
for thinking about communities
in the context of collections,
not allow us to see?
I think there's a tendency to
treat communities of practice
as though they might
be an emergent property
of materials and methods, right?
If you make materials available and
you have people who might be expert
in certain methods, or who are
becoming expert in certain methods,
they will find each other,
they will do amazing things,
and certainly that is true.
And some of the central
scholarship on communities
of practice can certainly be read
to support this sort
of quasi-emergent idea.
But in my experience, this is
really almost never the case.
We're not seeing something
important that's actually happening.
It's important to remind ourselves
that communities are not spontaneous
or organic, and to quote the
wonderful critical theorist,
Miranda Joseph, who's written
beautifully on the idea
of community, "To invoke community
is immediately to raise questions
of belonging, and of power."
And that I think is one area
in which the work we're doing
within the ADDHUM initiative is sort
of asking us to push beyond the idea
of communities of practice that
we've inherited from a kind
of organizational studies context.
And that context, it sort of
notoriously has done very little
to grapple with sort of
notions of power and dominance,
which of course an important element
of the communities
that we all live in.
I think it's important to
understand that communities
of practice are always communities
within other communities.
The work of designing them,
because it is intentional design,
and nurturing them, also
intentionally, will always be done
in the context of the communities
in which we already live.
The structures of power, the
relationships between people
of different backgrounds,
different experiences,
that exist in those
communities already.
We don't get to just sort wipe
the slate clean, and talk in very,
sort of narrow, technocratic terms
about communities of practice
as though they weren't
already imbricated
in the American community,
the D.C. community,
whatever community we find ourselves
living in, the campus community,
that we -- and we have to sort of
take this into account in terms
of both design and nurturing.
And maybe that not everyone who's
working in our community, you know,
comes to work you know, with the
same sort of emotional experience
of things happening out
there in the larger world.
And so, this is why I
think it's imperative not
to let the active work of
community development sort
of fall below the level
of our full attention,
because this work demands every
bit as much as the building
of collections, or the
development of tools.
And we are responsible
for the communities we
create or fail to create.
I think listening to the
talk earlier, you know,
we're working toward being maybe
a little bit more like some
of those fan [phonetic]
fiction communities
that we were hearing about.
And that might look
different from the way
that we understand communities
of sort of senior scholars
and junior scholars, or academics
and members of the public.
So, to try and explain a
little bit more of what I mean
in concrete terms, I'll say a little
bit more about how we're working
through these challenges
in the ADDHUM initiative.
The initiative is funded by a grant
from the Andrew W Mellon Foundation,
and we're about three-quarters
of the way
into the first year of
three years of work.
With the leadership of the dean of
the college of arts and humanities,
Bonnie Thornton Dill [phonetic], the
work of ADDHUM is led by the Center
for Synergy, under the direction
of Sherry Parks [phonetic]
and the Maryland Institute for
Technology in the Humanities
or MITH, under the direction of
my boss, Neil Frysat [phonetic].
Also, partnering in the
initiative are the Center
for Global Migration Studies,
the David C. Driscoll Center
for the Study of Visual Arts,
and Culture of African Americans
and the African [inaudible], as
well as the university libraries,
where I report to my other boss.
And the work of ADDHUM is
led by our faculty director,
Catherine Knight-Steele [phonetic],
and includes post-doctoral
associates, MITH digital humanities,
research faculty and staff,
an advisory board of scholars
from multiple disciplines
invested in the study
of African American culture and
history, librarians and archivists,
graduate assistants, and we hope
faculty, students, librarian
and cultural heritage professionals,
and members of a still wider
community that we hope to fold in.
And it's worth saying, since Harriet
mentioned, the earlier iterations
of the digital humanities
incubator which is part of our plans
for the ADDHUM initiative, that
we've gone from the first iteration
where it was solely focused on
building up skills and capacity
in among our librarians, to a model
where everyone is all
mixed together,
and we take on that
greater challenge
of having all these
people mixed together
with their different
experiences, different expertise,
because ultimately, I think that's
the way we need to be working.
And so, the goals of the ADDHUM
initiative are to advance
and expand the fields
of digital humanities,
and African American history and
cultural studies, and to develop
and diversify the pipeline for
the next generation of scholars
and professionals who foster
engagement at this intersection.
Which is to say that we are directly
engaged in building communities
of practice, in building
communities,
and that these communities will
be a measure of our project,
as much as any of the scholarship,
whether it be digital projects
or traditional publications, or
new courses, or public programing,
that we also produce, right?
We are willing to be measured by
the community that we are creating,
because that is a critical
part of the work
that the grant has
set itself out to do.
So, rather than produce a
single research project,
ADDHUM seeks to transform
both the digital humanities
and the African American
cultural studies fields.
And so, to accomplish
this goal, we'll you know,
we will do a number of things.
We will foster of cohort
of scholars and students,
working at this intersection.
This cohort will facilitate
all the kinds
of people that I just mentioned.
We'll be creating and revising
new courses at the University
of Maryland, in disciplines
related to African American history
and culture, which is
frankly all of them.
And to provide training and
development opportunities
to support local and regional
participants in conceiving
and producing new research.
I'm coming to that part in a second.
We're also planning to
organize a national conference
to bring together those parts
of this network that we can --
who are doing digital research
like this, that we can touch,
that we can reach, and to
oversee digitization description
of archival collections
at the Driscoll Center
and the George Meany Memorial
AFL-CIO Archive at the University
of Maryland Libraries, that
are relevant to research
on African American labor,
migration, and artistic expression,
which are the core themes around
which we're organizing our work.
And I want to stop here and
say also that this is only sort
of the latest entry in work
that many people have been doing
for a very, long time, right?
Again, we're not wiping
the slate clean.
It's not -- we are
not newly bringing
into being this collaborative
community between people working
in digital ways and people studying
African American history and life.
There's a long history of such work,
and we are just happy to be joining
that conversation,
trying to do our part.
So, lest the central point be
lost in all of these details,
the way I would describe
our community of practice,
our community, is to say that ADDHUM
is a community invested in the study
of African American history and
culture, and I want to phrase it
that way because I think often,
because of the history of the term
"communities of practice,"
we find ourselves using it
in far too technocratic
a sense, right?
That it's about skills
transfer or achieving some sort
of organizational mission.
And so, we're putting the
idea of all the different ways
that we could use digital methods,
digital tools, digital collections,
to study African American history
and culture, at the center.
And by no means does that mean
we are giving up being invested
in a vision of digital
work that explores new ways
of using computing, and that
is informed by you know,
the scholars who have studied
African American history
and culture before our
project even began.
And a lot of the work right now, is
sort of imagining the programming
that we call the digital
humanities incubators,
though we have called the digital
humanities incubators in the past.
And my colleagues,
Catherine Knight-Steele
and [inaudible] Linblad [phonetic]
are really leading this work
and I'm really sort of
reflecting and reporting
on the great work that
they are doing.
And as I kind of hinted,
the DH incubators have
been an evolving process,
where we started very much in the
idea focused on being a way of sort
of incubating project ideas, right?
Building particular
skills and capacities
such that librarians
could do digital projects.
And that has some positives
as far as they went,
but then the next time we got a
chance to run this programming,
we decided that we would
put the data at the center
and that has been a new idea that
has sort of stuck with us, right?
That we put the data in the center,
and ask our community all the ways
in which they might wish to
respond to it, without presuming
that we know particular methods or
techniques that we just simply need
to communicate outward to them.
The Scholar of Visual Culture,
Laura Wexler [phonetic],
makes a nice point with
regard to crowd sourcing,
and talking about how we go
beyond sort of using the crowd
for data collection or data
production, and being open
to all the other ways in which the
community might wish to respond
to a given dataset or a given
collection, and to also be open
to taking that in, even though
it goes beyond say perhaps
simple transcription.
And so, the idea of the
incubator is still evolving,
and we're evolving this
idea with the ethics
of building a community
fully in mind, right?
So, this perhaps means, "How do we
stay in touch with people who come
into contact with us or engaging
with us, for longer than we might,
if it was simply skills
training, right?
How do we build an
ongoing relationship?"
Another aspect of it is, "Where
do we do this work, right?"
We're all sort of embodied
people and the spaces
in which we do this work
and who else is in the room,
matters a lot about who
can access and who can feel
like they're part of our community?
So, that's an aspect that
we're really thinking about.
And [inaudible], pardon
my pronunciation,
who are sort of some key
practitioners from the tradition
of participatory design, have a
nice way of thinking about this,
and they are citing actually
the work of Lucy Suchman,
the feminist historian
of technology.
And she's arguing that we need
to get away from viewing things
as discreet objects, and
networks of devices, but instead,
to start viewing design work and
technological development as quote,
"Entry into networks of working
relations, including both contests
and alliances that make
technical systems possible."
And as [inaudible] Vincent
and [inaudible] Wright,
this is hard design work, where
various context or practices
and technologies concurrently
undergo change,
and therefore demand continuous --
what they call, "continuous
infrastructuring," and aligning
of partly conflicting interests.
So, I think it's useful to
think about the work we do
about building community around
collections, around data,
as this work of continuous
infrastructuring, to think about it
in terms of the people who
are in our communities,
the emotions that they're having,
the desires that they have,
the goals that they have, and then
to structure the work that we do
around how do we imagine sort
of aligning all those partly
conflicting interests,
not getting caught up in
the rush of finding people
who are just doing things like
us, but to think hard and do
that hard design work, to
do the hard design work
of continuous infrastructuring,
or of designing
and nurturing communities.
So, just as a closing thought,
it seems to me that communities
of practice may be a find starting
point, for how we imagine access
and use models, for
digital collections,
but it certainly can't
be the stopping point.
Most of the core scholarship on
communities of practice is 20
and 30 years old, which of
course doesn't make it outdated
in the humanities, but I'm
sure people have said lots
of interesting things since then.
And in the spirit of being good
interdisciplinary borrowers,
we should probably try to
engage those ideas as well.
And I think it's particularly
important, as we do this,
to think about how we
make collections as data
into what Miranda Joseph calls
"legitimate sites of
empathy of concern."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Marisa Parham: I'm
another computer person,
so give me a moment.
I've always had this dream that I
would chat and say witty things,
as I got set up, but
[inaudible], no.
I won't go so far as to
say the dream is dead,
but it's not thriving.
But fortunately, I have my
bag, my mommy bag of dongles.
So, I've been interested
today in sort of thinking
about how things can be
pulled together, right?
I'm not here necessarily
to pull things together,
but I'm always interested --
this is one of the problems
of coming up end of the day.
I'm sort of interested in
where we can find connections
between the things that
have always been said.
This my like way of copping out
of the fact that like I'm going,
so much at the end of the day,
and there's so much to say
because of course I've been sort of
hyper-stimulated by all the stuff
that people have said before.
So, I want to begin today by
thinking about the kinds of issues
that emerge when we think about
data as a personal matter.
So, often we speak of collections
at large, and we're thinking
about small things, right?
So, there's a way in which
we talk about collections
when we're thinking about sort
of you know, digital humanities
and library work and archives and
so on, but when you're thinking
about the raw material that
constitutes collections,
you're often just talking
about personal things, right?
Some point, much of what we
refer to as something pulled
into a collection was
something personal.
And that's a little bit of what
I want to talk about today.
Right? Collections are letters
in attics, the boxes of receipts,
piles of playbills
in someone's closet.
I had the huge privilege of being
able to go to the Museum of --
the National Museum of
African American History
and Culture opening this weekend,
and a lot was made I think
rightfully, of how so much
of this sort of material history
has been left out of conversation
because it's been squirreled
away in the attics of people
who are not included in those kinds
of archival conversations
previously.
So, it was really sort of weighing
on me as I prepared this talk
in thinking about collections.
I also want to think about what is
gained and lost in the transition
from one kind of narrative space,
the local and the personal,
into other kinds of
uses, the archival,
the computational, or so on.
And even though I prefer not to
belabor the usual dichotomies,
even though I kind of began with one
in my title, I've pulled this term
"Datum Storytelling," because
it helps me think about issues
that emerge at the intersection of
data, the way we talk about it now,
data, big data, so on, to reveal the
excavated, the collected, the scene,
and the personal, which can be
all those things, but also brings
with it, a sense of what
is at stake in ownership,
management, or the control thereof.
If we accept that there is
any conceptual value in data,
then we must also accept that
our lives have always been lived
in streams of data.
Data is the trace.
I'm thinking here of recent works.
For instance, the work
done by Lupi and Posavec,
this project you may have
seen called "Dear Data,"
in which to each person, they're
both artists, collected all kinds
of personal information, then
converted the personal information,
tracked over a week, into hand
drawn data visualizations.
I found this super
interesting, right?
I'll put it back so you
can see a little bit more.
I found this super interesting
because there was a way
in which it kind of took this
notion of tracking, right,
the watch you wear, the wearables
and so on, and made it back
into what we usually think of as an
easier kind of analog art, right?
So, I was interested then in sort
of how they talk about it as well.
This is a quote, "We've always
conceived 'Dear Data,'" they write,
"as a personal documentary, rather
than a quantified self-project,
which is a subtle, but
important distinction.
Instead of using data just to become
more efficient, we argue we use data
to become more humane, and
to connect with ourselves
and others at a deeper level.
For Lupi and Posavec, life is parsed
in the data and so transformed,
produces newly [inaudible]
raw material for art,
story, and visualization.
In 'Dear Data,' each datum
is self-consciously deployed
to tell a story."
Datum storytelling then, is a way
of thinking about intentionality
in archival development
collection, and without losing
at the same time, sight of people.
The sight of the human.
And later on, I want to
interrogate this notion
of the human just a little bit, but
for now, we'll go with this, right?
But when we're thinking about this
in data, the human, the person,
is a referent and I'm
thinking of a human
who can self-consciously
manage, disseminate,
parlay, and remix their trace.
This reminds me of some
of the restorative work
that we know happens as we age.
Telling stories and returning
to our personal collections,
grounds our sense of self very
much in that which is familiar.
And so, the metaphor I always use
for this is this notion of sort
of digging in the crates,
right, a sort of hip-hop term.
The idea is that this
is sort of archive
that you're constantly digging
through, but you're digging
through it with the
interest -- I'll put it back.
You're digging through it in
the interest of being able
to show people something new.
So, the archival is
specifically deployed.
Again, the new is made out of
the old, which sounds very corny
when you say it like that,
but when you're there, right,
it's a moment of intense,
sort of meaningfulness, right?
And it's very corny.
I was looking for it.
There's this old, sort of, you know,
God, it was really embarrassing
because I was looking for it and
I realized it was essentially
on a Coke commercial or something.
It won in some moment of marketing.
And it was this old, sort
of, you know, Mary J. Blige
and Method Man commercial,
and in that commercial they were
playing the song, "You're all I Need
to Get By," and it was like
a kid upstairs listening
to the hip-hop version, and then
the grandparents downstairs,
listening to the old, sort of
Marvin Gaye, Tammi Terrell version.
And the idea was like, they
showed the split space, the floor.
And upstairs, right, you have the
kid stomping out, and downstairs,
the grownups are like, "Yes, they
finally found the truth," right?
So, this notion of sort
of digging in the crates,
I've always found really
interesting.
And I think it's useful for thinking
about the individual making choices.
The generational and community.
It also brings to a
forefront, the idea of curation.
The idea that the past itself is a
collection, and that we think today
about processing that collection,
to give historical contour
to an otherwise infinitely
mutable present.
The idea of digging
in the crates brings
with it, the joy of discovery.
A joy amplified by
artistic transformations
that archival discovery will enable.
What is more difficult
to conceptualize however,
are the limits, or if there
should be a limit to that digging.
In an essay titled, "The Digital
Afterlife of Lost Family Photos,"
Teju Cole describes work done by the
artist Zun Lee, you can see it here
on the screen, called
"Fade Resistance."
In this project, Lee
takes as his medium,
found photographs of
African Americans.
So, the kind of stuff
we were talking about --
or I was talking about
in terms of the museum.
The stuff in attics, the
stuff at flea markets, right?
These collections of photographs
that have been orphaned now.
So, no one knows to whom they
belong, but we know of course
by virtue of being
photographs collected,
they were important to someone.
Right? How do we fill that gap?
How do we think about this?
Cole recounts one of Lee's
anecdotes from the project,
and I'm going to share it
here because it encapsulates
in a different way, how we might
experience the transition from data
to datum, in our increasingly
digital life worlds.
"Who took these photos?
Who do they depict?"
Cole asks.
"The basic contextual details,
we would usually expect
from snapshots are missing here.
The absence of this
information is bitter sweet.
We are bewildered, but
we are also ferried
over from the imagery
into imagination.
In Lee's case, the story
of his orphaned Polaroids
took a surprising turn.
When he uploaded some
of them to Facebook,
the social network's facial
recognition technology immediately
began to match then
with real people.
Lee was not sure who
was doing the tagging.
Intrigued and wary, he sent
a message to one individual
who was tagged in several
of the pictures.
There was no response.
Then several weeks later, he
got a message from the same man.
A curt request, that he
take the pictures down."
Of the experience Lee notes, I
quote, "He's already been thinking
about how databases and
tags are not neutral.
How they can wind up being hostile
towards communities of color.
I completely understand,"
Lee told Cole.
Quote, "This man was saying, 'We
are not willing participants.
The black body is used
as a commodity,
as something that is surveilled.'
The man was telling me,
'No, you're not welcome.
This is not art.
Get the hell out of our lives.'
And I understood it."
In so far as collection
bespeaks curation, in our work,
we must also be ready to think
about the rightful sense of danger
that the very idea of being
collected might bring.
And by extension, the technically
invasive work or conversion
of objects and moments into data.
The parsing and the combine.
So, it was important by the
way, I should note in this talk
that I'm actually quite
a technical person,
so it's kind of a shadow
technical talk behind this.
When I'm talking about sort of
parsing collections and data,
I'm thinking about some of the
stuff we got earlier today,
of thinking about using
images as text for instance.
I'm thinking about [inaudible].
I'm thinking about the ways in
which we break these larger things
down into smaller,
compartmentalized,
and remixable units, right?
The parsing.
So, to be clear, it's
like a shadow behind.
It's like detect shadow.
Right? But I only have so
much time, so I'm just rushing
through the other part for now.
Oh, I wish I could
have a super hero name,
like tech shadow, but whatever.
So, sorry.
So, I'm also taken with the
problem of disappearance,
which by the thought
works against this work.
In his essay, one example Cole turns
to actually is this one, this photo.
As he reads the back of
a photo, he says quote,
"It's adjust that it was paste into
an album, and then ripped out."
And people do this kind of work and
be -- and are familiar with this,
even sort of the blackness of the
glue which shows it was archive.
It was a particular kind of glue
that was used, so when it was paste
into the album, it was made to last,
but then it was nonetheless,
ripped out, right?
How do we map and mark
that transition?
How do we think about it?
As well, this is no mere
glue stick decision.
As equally significant
to us then in this image,
is what is hidden from us.
Much of what is at stake in this
example, comes down to ownership.
For the idea of personal collection,
is also an exercise in exclusion.
Right? And my example, is
that I've been doing work
for the last few years on
Octavia Butler [inaudible] archive
which is just amazing.
But whenever I'm working, I'm at
some points sort of overwhelmed
by a sense that I have
to be careful in thinking
about that archive
as her collection.
It's a collection of her stuff,
but insofar as she died, suddenly
and unexpectantly, and young,
we must as researchers live
with the fact that she had
little hand in this curation.
I always wonder what she would have
thrown away and as everything there
like little slips of
paper, receipts,
all kinds of private
information, right?
On the one hand, the fullness
of that archive is a boon
for researchers like
me, but because she's
so carefully otherwise
crafted her public life,
I know that her deletions would have
probably been just as instructive,
albeit ghostly, as is somewhat
wholesale and [inaudible].
I'm intrigued in thinking about what
it means for her to lose so much
of that narration, to lose
agency despite legacy.
Digging in the crates and permission
just really can't always coexist,
when we're thinking of the past.
Many of course have taken
up the ethical questions
of opening archives and so on, but
I just want to think about this
for a moment as a way of introducing
this notion of how we might mourn,
in the midst of opportunity.
But I'll move on.
At the forefront of thinking
about purpose in the [inaudible]
of digital work, for me
has been a commitment
to openness and we hear this a lot.
It's important work.
Which as many have pointed out,
unlock some of the negative
or oppressive ownership
relations historically associated
with resource enabled entities.
Collecting from sometimes
even willing, but usually not,
others when a big institution comes
and gets all your stuff, right?
Regardless, if openness, publicness,
and access, are the hallmarks
of decolonial approaches to archive
making, and I believe they are,
I am also nonetheless
interested in the meaningfulness
of exclusion, elision, and deletion.
But sometimes, even
[inaudible] making.
The meaningfulness in other
words, of storytelling.
I am thinking here of Michelle
Caswell's [phonetic] work
on thinking about the kinds
of agency made possible
through the collection, also the
deployment, of archival materials.
In inventing new archival
imaginaries, theoretical foundations
for identity-based community
archives, Caswell reminds us
that quote, "Memory archives
are not just memory activists,
but visionaries whose work
reconceives imagined worlds
through space and time."
In aligning archival work
with memory and its futures,
rather than only with historical
recovery representation of the past,
Caswell offers us a way to
think very instrumentally
about our own archival projects.
If, following Caswell,
archives are quote,
"Not just about documenting a
more diverse version of the past,
based on the identities of present,
but rather by uncovering
previously untold, ignored,
or misinterpreted histories."
Communities can imagine and
reimagine different trajectories
for the future, so it's
not just enough to say,
"We're going to expand our
archive by putting more kinds
of people into it," right?
This notion of empowerment
around the archive is also
about making the archive
available in such a way
that it can also be disseminated by
the communities that need it most.
Right? It's an important
distinction.
Thinking about this, I would argue,
gets us towards the generative
possibilities of eliciting data,
even computationally, from datum.
In a talk titled, "Networked
Knowledge, Digital Spaces:
Storytelling as Decolonial
Methodology," Emily Legg,
building on the work of scholars of
indigenous memory in history asks us
to think in very material
ways about quote,
"Storytelling as knowledge-making,
and a way of knowing
that it's not placed
within one individual
who passes down to others.
Instead, it is knowledge that
exists in a network state,
within a row of the community
as knowledge partners."
Again, I offer not all of this to
make a commentary on the difference
between storytelling and like
the [inaudible] versus data
and like the machines or something.
But that if we're thinking
about how to decolonize
that which is collected,
we must also be thinking
about knowledge transfer, and
therefore thinking differently
about design and interface.
The motion quote of knowledge is
seated in its [inaudible] context,
and emerges when we're supposed
to listen to it, the idea right,
is that you can't necessarily
approach and archive,
already knowing what
you're expecting to get.
A proper archive, and this
is something that's come
up all day today, it's
called serendipity, right?
The idea right, is that
the archive is a depository
that also teaches you, and
that teaching depends on you
on some level not knowing
what you're going
to get when you go there.
But as you can imagine, this is
a very compelling design problem.
How do we enable these
arrivals, right?
And underlying some of this,
right, I'm thinking about you know,
someone like [inaudible], right,
when we're decolonizing
knowledge points out, quote,
"Decolonization is not about only
design, tinkering with the margins.
It is about reshaping, turning human
beings once again, the craftsmen
and craftswomen, who in reshaping
matters and forms, need not to look
at preexisting models and need
not to use them as paradigms."
One of the deepest problematics
we know of so many archives,
or archival collections,
digital collections,
is that they're modeled, right,
on different kinds of repositories
that assume you're working
materially with the papers at hand.
The digital is in fact different.
I know many people are talking about
this, but when we're thinking again
about what interface can do, we need
to be parlaying the digital rather
than imagining we're reproducing
some lost art form, some lost world.
So, my idea of physical space in
its own ways was also oppressive.
So, at Five College Digital
Humanities, we try to really work
on ways of integrating
these sort of theoretical
and conceptual understandings,
alongside sort
of very material practice again.
It's like again, the sort
of shadow background.
I'm talking about real projects.
I'm talking about [inaudible].
I'm talking about D3.
I'm talking about all these things.
Right? I'm just trying to give you
a different visuality [phonetic]
for thinking it through.
A different kind of visualization.
One example of this work is a
Zine Scenes project [inaudible]
"Beyond the Riot."
That's been a really
interesting project.
Now, to say a little bit
more about it quickly.
It works with what are essentially
very localized zine collections.
So, small magazines made
in very small communities,
even just between friends.
And as you can imagine, this
holds a wealth of information
about women's lives, right,
in the last 30 to 50 years.
It holds enormous information,
right, about all the ways girls
for instance interact
with pop culture and ideas
about growing up and so on.
It's a corpus that's
impressive, but at the same time,
you're explicitly dealing
with materials that were made
on some level, to walk
a very fine line
between the private and the public.
Right? They're made to be
shared, but they're private.
That's a difficult
line to think about
and I think Twitter social media,
that gets in a similar place.
It's public but also
kind of private.
You wouldn't actually just jump into
someone else's Twitter conversation,
if you don't know the people.
And sort of thinking about
what that means, right?
So, they changed the project
-- not changed the project,
but sort of [inaudible]
the project in,
into thinking about not just
a repository, but a quote,
"interactive digital
subcultural platform."
Right? The PIs, Alana [inaudible]
and Michelle [inaudible]
from Hampshire College, and Leslie
Fields from Mt. [inaudible] College,
along with their [inaudible] DH
undergraduate fellow Norm Miller,
realized that not only does a
collection enable a vast number
of computational, mapping, and
visualization possibilities,
but that clicking -- but that
sorry, eliciting the narrative
and experiential meaningfulness
of these incredibly localized
and specific texts, also make
creating some form of encounter,
interface, that could
enable the user
to understand how the experience
of finding a zine is as important
as what the zine itself holds.
That the experience of
navigating the archive is
as much an educational experience
as finding the actual object,
which the archive holds.
Much of the zine's value then,
reproduces what we've been reading
about and thinking about in terms
of sort of indigeneity in archives,
in reproducing a [inaudible]
moment of discovery, right?
A moment when you realize,
"This is it.
I did not know this was it.
How did I live without this?
What is this?"
Much like musical improvisation,
this sense of discovery
requires the production
of an incredibly, deeply
tagged archive.
So, this thing I'm calling
[inaudible] and spontaneous,
in fact requires an eminently,
deeply tagged, meta data,
machine readable, structure,
because if we imagine
that interfaces can function in the
kind of flexible ways that we would
like them to, the ways
I would like them to,
I'm getting away from
the [inaudible].
It's a sad day.
But, in ways we want them to
work, right, then there's a way
in which we have to go
in the opposite direction
of what one imagines this
conversation might go, right?
We turn back to the
machine readable.
compartmentalize.
We turn back to the smallest bits
of data, because it requires, sorry,
it produces the flexibility
that makes possible more kinds
of interfaces, more
kinds of exchanges.
It's a quandary.
We have to break it even
more than we realized.
This means moving away from
retrieval as the archive's purpose.
And instead, focusing
on enabling users
to personalize their encounters, to
bring what they made to the archive,
and by virtue of their
own specificity,
use it to make their own things.
I'm happy to say more about this,
particularly as the Zine
Scene's project must also grapple
with the kinds of resistance that
Teju Cole wants us to think about.
When to exclude, and when to delete?
Many items in the collection
were likely produced by people
who never intended for them
to be disseminated at the kind
of scale digitization
makes possible.
They might want to share it, but
the digital is something else
and it's something none of us
could imagine 30 years ago.
Again, if we imagine the most
critically informed, decolonial,
future oriented perspective
on archives,
that work must still nonetheless,
grapple with the question of refusal
that must be the part of any
democratic understanding of data.
At any moment, datum, the
individual, must be recovered
by being extracted from data,
never to be returned again.
I'll stop there.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.Loc.gov.